Samantha is with us in New York City hi
Samantha how are you hi this is so
awesome I'm glad you got through how can
I help
okay so I am currently in a relationship
but I plan to break it off my concern is
I am very financially dependent on him
so how do I set myself up without
getting into debt okay what is your
household income what not house or what
do you make
I currently make forty thousand okay and
well one thing you need to do is to lay
out a budget and a game plan that says I
can live on forty thousand okay and in
other words you lay out your what your
rents going to be and you know what your
lights are and your water and your food
and and here's how I'm going to make it
on forty thousand or here's what I'm
gonna do to get my income up so I can
make it what do you do for a living I'm
currently a housing specialist I help
low-income families find housing okay
cool all right well I don't know in the
sometimes when you do a transition like
this you might have to take on some
extra work to create some extra money to
help you get the next place and deposits
and whatever else and that kind of a
thing right but but what what will
emotionally set you free is just jump on
every dollar calm and build yourself out
of budget with your income only and go
hey here's how I can make it and here's
what I would do and here's what I would
spend on food and here's what I would
spend on this here's what that's been on
that and just lay your you know lay your
like new life out on paper and when you
see you can make it that takes a lot of
the teeth out of the fear monster you
know what I'm saying yeah so why are you
breaking this off
um it's not working anymore hmm okay so
can you make it have you ever laid it
out see if you can make it on 40 no
because everything is so expensive here
yeah it is now New York's an expensive
market to live in you live in
hatton or one of the other boroughs well
currently I live in New York I'm Long
Island with okay yeah it's expensive
you're right you're right so you may
have to think about what you're going to
do with your life as a part of this but
if it's not working we got to reset your
life and you need to lay out a game plan
to make it on your income which sets you
free to be able to go do what you want
to do and live the life you want to live
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]